hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in book three of his work on
anger Seneca is going to make an
argument to us his readers that anger is
not only a vice and a bad Vice but the
worst of all of the vices and this is a
pretty strong statement on his pardon so
he's going to make an argument by
raising all sorts of points many of
which are comparisons between anger and
the other vices sort of heaping up
evidence for the claim that he wants to
make and you might say well why is he
doing this what is the point of making
an argument like this well there's a
certain rhetorical Force to saying that
this is a incredibly serious matter one
that we need to address and root out
entirely which is part of the point that
he wants to make and chapter one and
chapter two are not the only places
where he's going to say that anger is
indeed you know the worst but a lot of
arguments are concentrated there so
we're going to focus just on those
arguments that he's providing and we'll
see they're already quite a lot
and he begins by saying after talking
about how we need to address anger in
different people in different ways he
says all other Passions tolerate being
put off and are to be treated slowly but
anger's violence and he uses the word
violantia there right so this this
impetus that it has once it has been
aroused in Kita and is hurrying along
speeding along it doesn't progress
little by little but instead it is
present or as a complete phenomenon or
you know to use the Latin word Tota
there which means whole as a totality
once you get angry once you actually
proceed to the point where you're out of
control you are as angry as you can be
and so he goes on and he says here's
another consideration it doesn't just
trouble our minds in the ways of other
vices right the other vices will make us
you know think about things and tempt us
and all that but anger actually as he
said says leads the Mind astray abducate
so this is from ducare to lead right and
ab means a way away from what we should
be focusing on and then it drives them
ex agitat what does it drive people into
it leads them astray drives them on when
they lack self-control and are eager
even for an evil in which all will share
so there's something about anger
that's different than the other vices
and we couldn't stop and reflect on this
for a moment you know he's going to talk
later about lost and greed and ambition
right so ambition isn't ambition that
everybody uh in some way benefit or
suffer it's for me right same thing with
lust if I'm filled with lust I'm not
like I'm gonna go have sex with that
person and I want you to feel that way
too anger tends to spread itself out in
different ways right
and he goes on with that and he says how
does it lead us astray it rages not only
against targets it's marked out the
people that were actually angry at but
against Whatever Gets in its way a
person wants angry will easily turn that
anger on somebody who's you know
defending the other person who's even
saying hey man calm down one of the best
ways to get an angry person to turn
their ire at you is to tell them that
right so that's that's an interesting
secondary argument
he also contrasts anger against the
other vices in terms of we could call it
its ability to be
recalled he says all the other vices
give our minds a shove right they push
us in a certain direction anger pitches
them headlong so this is a difference we
could say not an absolute kind but in
intensity he says even if it's not
possible to resist one's passion
questions at least the passions
themselves may come to a standstill you
know is that the case with all the
passions if we think about this maybe
that's not a great argument greed
doesn't seem to have any bounds maybe
ambition doesn't either but lust
certainly does you feel sexual desire
you go and have sex now you're for a
little while at least you're not so
interested in it the vices come to an
end same with gluttony or you know other
things we could say but anger once you
actually slide into it
there's no coming back Seneca is saying
he says he's got this great example this
one accelerates anger uh just like
lightning bolts and storm gusts and
anything that can't be called back
because they don't just move they Plunge
so earlier on he actually talked about
uh you know this this metaphor of
jumping off a cliff before you actually
jump you got a choice right you may have
somebody pushing you like the anger
but if you don't jump you're good but
once you jump you can't say you know
halfway down you know I don't think this
is a great idea I think I'd like to go
back up there no it's it's on its way
so Seneca sees this as something
distinctive to anger
um he goes on and he's got this
interesting quip which we also need to
think through a little bit the other
vices rebel against or they they're
disobedient to they incline away from
the Senate
reasoni right
uh anger goes against reason but it also
goes against as Seneca is going to say
sanity and you can say what's the
difference here if you're irrational
um aren't you insane well maybe you have
to have more to actually be insane
remember Seneca defines anger very early
on in the text as a brief Madness but I
think that we should see this not just
in terms of mental processes but we
could also think about it in a more
Global sense in terms of the Mind and
Body together
anger Rebels against the health sanitate
of the mind and the body both of them
together right so now is that a good
argument I mean we could say that
gluttony also Rebels you know it makes
the stomach larger and capable of
absorbing more food and maybe lust does
things and so does ambition but this is
an argument that that Seneca is making
he's going to shore this up by saying
others other vices approach gently and
increase without our noticing about an
anger our minds are hurled straight down
and so no passion is more stunning in
its Force eager to follow its own
violent course arrogant and success
crazed when frustrated so you know those
might be
sub considerations for why we should
think that anger Rebels not only against
reason but also against sanity as well
and then he's got a very interesting
observation this brings chapter one to a
close
so anger unlike the other vices when
it's beaten back by perhaps ourselves or
good counselors or other people even
when it's beaten back it doesn't say
enough is enough
when the adversary had the good luck to
get away it turns to biting itself now
this is a Trope that we do see other
theorists of anger talking about that
anger can be turned against its own very
self right in this case Seneca talks
about it as biting that's a
characteristic word associated with
anger is a metaphor
and this is not the case of anger being
directed against itself so as to rein it
in it's rather that it's so frustrated
that it cannot reach its targets that it
turns inward on the person who feels it
and you know the anger wounds itself it
tears itself it lacerates itself so this
is a very common Trope that we see uh
discussed quite a bit in later
literature so these are a bunch of
considerations that he's sort of like
listing off one after the other and then
in chapter two he's going to bring up
two other really important
considerations again why anger is worse
than the other vices and indeed is the
worst of the vices so another has to do
with its extent and by that we can mean
not just how far anger will go but who
can feel it so
you know he's going to say not every
other Vice is necessarily
felt by other people so he gives some
examples right some Nations thanks to
the Boon of poverty don't know luxury
some because they're Nomads ever on the
move don't know laziness others with an
uncivilized and rustic way of life don't
know trickery and deceit or any of the
evils The Forum breeds so you know
that's good I mean it's not good that
they live say in poverty right or that
they don't know much about human beings
but that does at least keep them from
feeling certain emotions and falling
into certain vices
everybody
can be angry according to Seneca there's
no exemption for as he says stages of
Life Meaning being young being old being
somewhere in the middle no exemption for
class of people and we might think
social class in that case the the poor
the rich but he also is going to
contrast men and women right and
others as as well when he gets to how
anger can be shared right the foremost
and the mob the people who are at the
top the people who are at the bottom
anybody can get angry so nobody is free
of it and that's another reason we need
to be you know more careful about it and
so it is this an argument for it being
the worst it's not worst in the same
sense that these are but it is worse
than the other vices in that it can grip
anybody no matter what their condition
is unless of course their condition is
having worked on their anger and gotten
it in check the other thing that he
brings up is very interesting
it involves something a psychological
Dynamic that we have come to call later
on
emotional contagion and Seneca is trying
to argue that the only uh
emotion that we have this social
contagion in in a very broad sense going
on with is anger and he's not just
talking about a crowd he's talking about
like an entire populace of people so he
says that where whereas other vices
seize upon individuals right human
beings as particular human beings this
is the one passion that a whole populace
sometimes contracts or literally that
grips concippi tour and entire people
public right a a
mass of people and he goes on and he
says an entire people here's some
contrast says never burned with love for
a woman right so lust
you know we feel this individually right
we could feel it in a group I suppose
particularly with parasocial
relationships but
it's still not something that we're all
acting on together greed right he says
that
um nor has an entire Community placed
all its hopes on money or gain and again
we could say well I mean there's
communities that are pretty greed
focused but it's not the entirety of a
community and he says ambition seizes
individuals one at a time loss of
self-control is not an evil shared Out
Among a whole people but
a whole people has often not just once
in a while often become angry on Moss
and here's here we go back to that
everybody can get angry men and women
old and young the foremost in the mob
come to share a single thought and the
whole multitude whipped up by a word or
two outstrips the agitator himself
straight away they scatter to seize
torches and declare war on their
neighbors or wage it amongst themselves
once again we see that the anger can not
only be directed at an external object
but even within right and so he gives
some examples whole houses are
incinerated along with their households
a man who is highly honored for
eloquence becomes the victim of the
anger his own harangue has arousal
aroused Legions turn their Spears on
their own Commander you know and he goes
on and on we don't need to necessarily
go over all of these cases because we
can think about similar cases in our own
time where a entire group of people have
been motivated by anger and that anger
once aroused needs to find Targets might
not be satisfied with destroying the
person that they go after or the people
that they go after at the start and it
may even like lead to anger within the
group as well so this is a reason that
Seneca argues anger is worse than the
other vices to bring this to a close
Seneca is drawing very very stark
contrast between anger and other vices
do we have to buy the entire claims
argument that is being made or could we
say you know there's there's something
to this maybe anger isn't as completely
different from the other vices as Seneca
is rhetorically arguing at this point
but it certainly is more problematic
right and perhaps the most problematic
of the different vices for these reasons
because it does this sort of stuff more
often like the emotional contagion or
the uh you know turning on itself when
beaten back or any any of these other
matters but this is why Seneca himself
is claiming that anger is the worst of
all of the vices that we can think of
and Fall prey to